good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy wednesday happy
hump day time to hump someone you love
we are back on the interface hey claude
how are you doing
hello i am back home in new york
rash in tow
and you know what i wasn't worried about
the rash until i discussed the rash on
the podcast and now i have hordes of
medical professionals letting me know i
most likely have cellulitis which i
already knew you know you knew it was
cellulitis no i knew i had cellulite
oh lol oh no i mean that's what you get
when you talk about any medical ailments
you know in a public forum or just even
show your face like people are gonna let
you know what they think is wrong with
you but in this case it seems like they
hit the nail on the head 100 like what
everyone was describing apparently
cellulitis is extremely common and it
can be very serious if you don't get it
checked out which is what i'm going to
do after our show wraps up today but now
that we're back in studio you know with
our integrated interface i thought i
would maybe show everyone my rash if
they're interested i think that people
would want to see and that could also
help you know this virtual diagnosis
that's happening yeah and it's worth
mentioning like it has gotten worse
oh
i thought it was going to get better
let's see
it's just this patch of red
and it varies in its color like
throughout the day i really just need to
go get it checked out because
people are saying like people are
scaring me but they're right like let me
get it checked out so i can have some
peace of mind but i just think like of
course i would contract something called
cellulitis like that is just so me yeah
no it's not you know
it's not cygapilitis it's not stunning
itis
it's not
gorgeous beautiful setting and
smartieitis no it's cellulitis and
that's just me
yeah no that's a tough one
they should rebrand they should be grand
it's bad enough i have this like itchy
arm then i have to go around telling
people i have cellulitis like that's
just embarrassing yeah they need a new
name for it 100
well i'm glad that you're getting the
attention that that you require we're
glad that you're home
safe you know feeling good back to
business we are excited we actually have
so much to talk about today
fast five of course vanderpump rules
dear toasters it's gonna be a doozy
it's gonna be a doozy i just watched
vanderpump rolls i have a lot of
thoughts on the season finale it was
very um
it was grinding my gears
i have a lot of emotional responses and
they skew in the angry category
from last night's episode like
it really rounded out the season of this
these feelings that i have and like just
brock and it really all came to a head
and i i feel semi-vindicated but i also
feel like so many people are just
completely [ __ ] wrong tom and ariana
oh my god but they're like kind of
always wrong
always like you can always count on them
to have the worst takes ever and like
side with the wrong people yeah so
that's not surprising but it was just
nothing if not consistent it was it was
a crazy episode the reunion looks really
crazy
and i'm excited for all of that so we
will recap that other than that did you
consume any other content
no like i flew home from austin
yesterday i watched hours and hours of
tick tock
and that's really all i have to bring to
the table i apologize i didn't read i
didn't watch tv today i'm gonna catch up
on euphoria and cheer so i'll have more
to add tomorrow but yesterday was just
like a crazy travel day and i'm so happy
to be home like there's just nothing
better there's nothing quite like home
no there's nothing quite like home i
actually started a new book last night
even though i've been sort of burnt out
on reading i realized i'm burnt out on
like these like fiction you know boy
meets girl sort of books like i just
needed a break but what i'm interested
in is like i was feeling like a
non-fiction vibe like i just want to
like learn something about something i
don't know a lot about and i was
thinking back i really liked the book
good morning monster and when i posted
that a lot of people said i should read
this book maybe you should talk to
someone by laurie gottlieb and
they said it was really similar so i
just started that book and it's good i
just like wanted something
not like plotty just different
knowledgeable and something like
something that i don't know a lot about
so between that and podcasts like i'm
really trying to find
new hobbies but it's it's it's rough i
was talking to snitch last night she was
suggesting some hobbies for me to take
up like knitting
that's what she said i don't think
that's for me
and also just like sitting there hunched
over knitting it doesn't sound like you
can't leave your back when you knit i
knit it's so relaxing it doesn't sound
comfortable she actually had a great
suggestion
which was to take up the keyboard
oh yeah you have one in your house i
have one but it's like not it's not in
my house it's like in our storage unit
and it's not really accessible so i
don't know if i can get it but that
actually i thought was a great idea
could you imagine that's a good
suggestion it's worth trying to get the
keyboard out of storage me and bruce
playing chopsticks
ooh you and bruce like uh a cabaret duo
he'll sing and you play that would
actually be really fun so maybe i'll
work on that but if anybody has any
hobbies like at this point you guys know
my interests
so
please make any recommendations for
hobbies content anything that you think
i would like including podcasts that are
video
you can also
um start scrapbooking
i could
but i won't you know what that's good
that's the last thing i need is more
crap in my house oh by the way like
you're preaching to the choir like
that's why i won't take up a hobby like
i refuse to clutter up my house even
more yeah like all the ribbons and pens
and paper like no
yeah you would need like a craft room
too much
crap agreed
so that's where i'm at please send any
recommendations for some my and also i
do want to use the time wisely so
nothing that's like too mundane i really
even thought about like downloading tick
tock because that's really what's
missing is like
that sort of like mindless scrolling
because i do that on instagram now and
like i'm out of posts to look at and
then i'm like that loser who's seen
everything on instagram
so i was like this is why people
download tik tok but i refuse i'm not
going to regress
i need you to
know like i would 100 support you in the
redownloading of tick tock i know that
you would but i've come this far and
they're i'm not gonna break okay
so i want to use the time wisely
and to be intellectually stimulated let
me know your thoughts
okay that's a good idea i'd like that
for you thank you um how are you feeling
how are you doing how's lc
everything's pretty good it's crazy in
the mornings i really feel so good like
when we're toasting everything like i
have so much energy and then i would say
starting at like two o'clock it's just a
steady decline by the evening i'm so
uncomfortable i'm so tired fatigued like
even just sitting in bed is tiring and
like and i also don't fall asleep
immediately so it's just like
so exhausting just laying there there's
so much going on in the belly but the
mornings are
our business as usual elsie really
respects the toast and knows that we
have to do what we have to do so i'm
grateful for that
you know i feel like the first
like couple months of your pregnancy
flew by like you just somehow were like
six months pregnant and it was like in a
day
and now it feels like it's really slowed
down
i mean for me none of it has flown by
it's oh really no yeah because it's
every stage has been so different like
the first three months you would think
flew by because i was doing stuff and i
it was like i was less focused on it but
i was just like so anxious and excited
to like announce everything or like to
see the belly change that it didn't feel
like it was moving fast enough
and now obvious now things have really
slowed to a crawl but just every
time along the way like i just felt like
i was always waiting to like be more
pregnant and when i hit this milestone
like it was just
um i was always looking like to the next
thing so it felt like i was never there
yet yeah
well
i apologize but it feels like it's been
so quick
i'm glad because i like i
as a consumer i when other people's
pregnancies feel like they go on forever
but i think it's also just in relation
to like how much you talk about it and
totally a big thing
you like don't talk about it
yeah no i'm like when people ask me i
just i don't have much to say
right she's like i know i've been home
i'm good with bro
you know brew brew is pregnant by proxy
so you could ask him what it feels like
okay i will have to have brew on the
next episode
bryce mommy loves you so much mr
handsome
thrice i love you so much you're my king
reuniting reuniting with thea was
like a life-changing moment for me like
it was he was screaming i was screaming
it was six days without theo and that
was really hard and so coming home and
running into his arms was just magical
truly magical that's so special
it is
i'm happy for you guys
other than all of that
chilling like a villain ready to get
into it so let me know are you ready do
you think it's time yeah we have so much
to do we just like we're lollygagging
yeah okay so without further
lollygagging without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast wow
and today's episode is brought to you by
thread up did you know that by choosing
one used garment instead of a new one
you can save 77 gallons of water
thread up an online consignment and
thrift store is working to do the planet
good and give life to like new clothing
so
thread up is a place that you can thrift
your favorite brands from gap to gucci
all up to 90 off estimated retail value
it's one of the largest online thrift
stores like i said you can save up to 90
off the estimated retail value you get
insane deals
while thrifting with the convenience of
online shopping and with over 2 million
like new items to shop and thousands of
new arrivals daily it's the best place
to shop for your wallet and for the
planet you can customize your search by
your size style and budget so you can
find the best deals for more than 35 000
brands like banana republic madewell
nike and taylor loft instantly thread up
also has an easy return policy so they
make thrifting worry free
so thread up is fabulous for a multitude
of reasons but i think you'll be really
shocked when you go on there and see the
quality and the brands it's not your
it's not like other thrift stores and
it's all done online they have really
good customer service super good return
policy it's just a different thrifting
experience where you get sickening
clothes and you get to help save the
planet and thread up is offering a deal
just for new customers so right now if
you go to threadup.com
you can get up to an additional 50 off
plus free shipping on your first order
so that's an addiction additional
50 off plus the free shipping on your
first order just by going to
threadup.com that's t-h-r-e-d-u-p
dot com for up to 50 off and free
shipping on your first order great okay
our first story is some sad news this
morning vogue legend andre leontally has
died at the age of 73.
fashion legend andre leontally who
served as vogue's creative director and
editor-at-large died on tuesday at the
age of 73 tally who became the first
african-american creative director of
the magazine in 1988 died at the white
plains hospital from an unknown illness
according to tmz which first reported
the news his death was confirmed by his
friend darren walker who's president of
the ford foundation
he said in a statement andre leontaly
was a singular force in an industry that
he had to fight to be recognized in he
called him a creative genius and noted
his ability to craft a persona for
himself out of a deep academic
understanding of fashion and design
whenever i think of andre lee on tally i
always think of you because you loved
his book right loved his book and i'm so
glad that i read it and if you are
looking for a great memoir non-fiction
read i would say this is the book for
you and what a
you know
harmonious time to be reading it and
learning more about his life and his
story which is so incredible i mean i
feel like before i read the book i knew
andre leontelli from like america's next
top model and just like yeah from like
fashion
i think he was actually even had a cameo
when devil wears prada yeah exactly he
was just like this fashion guy but
hearing like learning his story
firsthand from him was it it was
so incredibly interesting and inspiring
and this is a great loss for the world
and the fashion community for sure
so what did he do at vogue he was a
creative director
got it got it and then i think over the
years like i mean in the last few years
his role sort of like petered out and
there's been like a lot of
silent
like conflict with anna wintour and
unclear
yeah because like they were so close
like they came up together at vogue and
in the fashion world and like they came
up in the days of like
karl lagerfeld and like really like the
the heyday of like fashion and new york
city and they worked really for a long
time together at vogue but i think
towards the end it didn't really end
well but it's unclear how it ended um
but i think there was probably like a
lot of like mutual respect there but i
don't think they ended their friendship
in like the way that it started
got it yeah well i've been reading you
know people's tributes and seeing
different photos and it's just so sad
because it seemed like he was someone
who was enormously talented but also
like extremely funny extremely
personable like a family guy
so
i actually think um his book is gonna be
on my
must-read list for this year i think
that you would love it and um get so
much out of it and i think for everyone
else especially if you love a celeb
memoir which has been so long since i've
read one i actually almost last night
started reading uh matthew mcconaughey's
memoir because i've heard so many good
things i mean it's like still on the new
york times bestsellers list and it came
out the same time that mine did like
literally over a year ago but
i just don't i think i have enough of an
interest in him
a baseline interest to pick it up i know
because he's just like a guy yeah he's
just a guy
so
i've heard great things about colin
josts
again i don't think i have enough of a
baseline interest
i think i might only because of like
scarlet but if you have an interest in
fashion and like fashion history
uh the chiffon trenches by andre
leontally would that's a question for a
book sickening
sickening yeah so this is definitely a
loss and it's quite sad but
his legacy is iconic and he's left us
with so much creative goodness
totally
are you ready for our next story
yes yes i am not to fatigue you all but
the spear sisters are at it again
brittany sent a legal letter for jamie i
just want to say cease and desist i just
want to say like i am fatigued you're
fatigued but like the whole world is
living for it yeah yeah i've just like
had enough and
now it's legal because yeah britney's
team sent a cease and desist letter to
jamie lynn to stop um
her press tour talking about britney so
britney is demanding her sister jamie
lynn leave her out of her book tour for
her new memoir things i should have said
asking her high-powered attorney matthew
rosengart to enter the fray brittany
issued a forceful cease and desist
letter exclusively obtained by page six
to her younger sibling in it britney
lets jamie lynn know that she will no
longer be bullied for the supposed
benefit of book sales
the letter says dear ms spears jamie
lynn as you know i represent your sister
brittany and i write at her request
concerning the above referenced matter
we write with some hesitation because
the last thing britney wants is to bring
more attention to your ill-timed book
and it's misleading
or outrageous claims about her
ill-timed book ill-timed book sums it up
completely whether it was ill-timed
intentionally or accidentally is still
to be seen but this also has me
wondering so the new the second part of
the call her daddy with jamie lynn is
supposed to come out today i think
oh so
is this cease and desist like retro i
think it will probably still come out
you know she already did the the
interview and so it maybe it's like stop
talking about me from here on but if you
talked about me a week ago what can i do
yeah like starting now
so all the old stuff like we'll still
get to see i think we'll it'll still
go up um you do
so that's interesting but i mean it's
really it's so true like it it's like
enough already enough especially because
she's not like saying kind things like i
feel like she's always you know saying i
care about brittany and this and that
but she's also like dragging her and
sharing like extremely personal stuff so
apparently in the interview she talks
about how um
like when britney and justin broke up
justin wrote the song crimey river like
about
brittany and brittany wrote the song
every time about the breakup with justin
and apparently like in all of these
years brittany has never admitted that
that song was about him and she just
gave it away
so it's like [ __ ] like that and that's
not even like so bad that's just like
personal
right just like stop sharing my [ __ ]
right and and it's not your story to
tell once again
so i understand my britney is fed up but
these two have got to work it out like
they need to go on
mori dr phil yeah i um
feel confused about this because i feel
like jamie lynn's whole spiel about her
book and all this press is like
nothing was ever about me
and even the press that she's getting
for her book
isn't about her yeah because she is not
making it about her
you know like because you know even when
she talks about herself if in the same
breath she's talking about brittany like
that's the headline because that's what
people care about but like right
like is she making it about britney or
is the press making it about brittany i
think that's a valid question no i think
it's it's still her because if britney's
name never come out of her mouth there
would be nothing to say
yeah
but she just like wants
i don't know people to like listen and
then focus on the stuff that she went
through but it's like at this time in
2022 when
the free britney movement is has reached
a fever pitch
they're just not gonna care so much
about
stuff also like the stuff jamie's trying
to like tell us like about her childhood
her book her story like
she's like not interesting enough like
at all
yeah i mean i guess i have to read the
book to to make that
oh here's the question are you gonna
read the book no no no no even though i
am in a non-fiction state of mind and i
have been craving a celebrity memoir
i don't know if this is the one for me
but i think because i'm watching the
podcasts i i feel like i'm i'm getting
enough you know i don't
i don't need to like over saturate with
this story considering
it's already it's already so crazy i
mean and even britney like posted uh
another instagram post
yesterday like talking about jamie lynn
and it's like
it's too much
no it's like for so long these two like
never even acknowledged each other like
now everything on their social medias is
about each other it's just crazy like
how do we get here i don't know and i
don't know how all of you are just like
keeping up and interested honestly
yeah we are it's the job but i don't if
as a lay person
i'm getting spears fatigued i would not
be yeah i'm getting spears fatigued they
need to like sit down together in a
quiet room and suss it out or don't like
or don't but just like
stop no but i'm always gonna be on the
time like team sisterhood
of course not screw sisterhood screw
sisterhood i just think like it might be
like too far gone for them
yeah for britney i feel like it is like
if jamie wanted to reconcile
britney like wouldn't but if brittany
wanted to reconcile like these two would
be good
because brittany's the one who has the
forgiving to do right also speaking of
this um you did wind up watching
yesterday the rachel segler
yes video and i would love to know your
thoughts having watched it now it was
really really painful to watch so
i i stand by what i said yesterday in
the sense that like it's a funny concept
but if you're gonna execute it it has to
be executed so great that like it makes
the risk you're taking worth it and i
just felt awkward and painful watching
it and it was
not worth the backlash because it wasn't
even funny or well done uh but i don't
know if it was ever intended to be funny
i like i think it was just like you know
like a theater
girl theater kids are bizarre like let's
just say that yeah it was like a theater
kids afternoon activity
like a drama class
rehearsal like
strategy like tactic some people
scrapbook other people do dramatic
readings of other people's instagram
captions yeah and it was just not
when i heard the concept i'm like oh
that's funny and then i saw and i was
like eek
yeah it was a lot
it was very icky it was very icky okay
ready for our next story
yes it's some mindless celeb news that i
thought was interesting because heidi
klum revealed on ellen that her legs are
insured for 2.2 million dollars
wow she said when when uh your legs are
the focal point of everything she didn't
say this this is people magazine you'd
better have those babies insured she did
for a while uh
though
one of her legs was worth less than the
other leg it 200 000
less because she has a scar on it
so
yeah so her legs are insured for 2.2
million dollars which led people
magazine to do a roundup of other
celebrity body parts that are insured
okay let me think like jlo definitely
insured her ass
same with maybe kim
well i just wanna i have another
question about heidi klum so so what
does that mean like if she gets into a
shark attack and they bite her leg off
she gets paid her 2.2 million dollars i
guess so that's like how insurance works
and they put a value on their legs so
like what would the value of my legs be
11 cents
yeah
like okay so like did she make up that
figure or did the insurance company i
think the insurance company does their
evaluation and based on like how much
work her legs get her yeah yeah yeah
okay so here are some more celebrity
insured properties holly madison's
breasts are insured for one million
dollars
rihanna's legs are insured for one
million dollars that's crazy dolly
parton's breasts are insured for six
hundred thousand dollars six hundred
million it should be six hundred million
i thought that's what you were gonna say
bruce springsteen's vocal cords are
insured for six million dollars
wait what you couldn't share your vocal
cords i guess so if he lost his voice he
would get six million dollars but also
you have to remember like when you have
insurance like you have to pay
them every month yeah like like my
favorite meme says the thing about
insurance is best case scenario you just
wasted a ton of money
right right mariah carey's vocal cords
and legs together 70 million dollars
how is
how is that worth more than bruce
springsteen i guess it's in the eye of
the beholder right the insurance company
david beckham and cristiano ronaldo both
have their legs insured david beckham's
for 195 million dollars and cristiano
ronaldos for 145 million
wow that's insane what body part would
you ensure i was actually thinking that
um well i guess what
it would have no but since we're
podcasters
oh right like what is like you know your
source of income i mean voice voice but
also like brain
breasts
no the interface cuts us off at the
chest totally no but we use our brains
and our mouths
yeah i wonder if you can insure your
brain
i wonder
i mean these people are ensuring a lot
of stuff america herrera has her teeth
insured for 10 million dollars
are they that great i don't i've never
really looked at them her smile is like
iconic sort of yeah well i when i think
of her smile i think of the braces she
had an ugly betty
true she was protecting her teeth right
and then jamie lee curtis's legs are
insured for one million dollars
get it girl get it girl so
that's just some interesting factoids
for the day i love finding out like how
rich people spend their money you know
it's so interesting yeah but it does
make sense i think in certain fields
especially if you're an athlete like and
you were to lose your source of income
you know right you have insurance i
agree it makes sense on like a basic
level but just hearing that somebody
have their legs insured is bizarre yeah
yeah but that's like celebrity stuff
that you don't really hear about anymore
but i feel like back in the day
used to happen more often
it reminds me of that scene from mean
girls like i hear her hair is insured
what did she say
i don't know one of the things they
heard about
or maybe her legs
yeah
whatever yeah that's what i think of
okay i'm glad to hear it
are you ready for our next story
yes a little more celebrity physique
news amy schumer is showing off her
weight loss after liposuction saying i
feel good
amy schumer says she finally feels good
after a lengthy battle with
endometriosis and a bit of liposuction
the stand-up comedian showed off the
results of her procedure with a photo of
herself wearing a bathing suit on the
beach saying i finally feel good it's
been a journey thanks for helping me get
through get my strength back she tagged
two doctors one for endo and one for
lipo she joked that she never thought
she'd go for plastic surgery but decided
to after her uterus didn't contract for
two and a half years and she turned 40.
she also credited her acupuncturist and
the talk spa for rounding out her health
and wellness journey so she is being
extremely candid about work that she's
had done now that she's turned 40 and
how she never really thought like she
would be someone who's into that and now
she's going for everything and she
thinks you know everyone who wants to
participate should yeah um
she also shared that she had fillers but
um she wasn't into them quote turns out
i was already full okay i saw that story
like last week where she said turns out
i was already full and i thought that
was the funniest thing ever because
that's a similar way to people always
ask like do you get filler i'm like
no i have a natural it's called
cellulitis like i have a natural filler
like i don't need to be more full yeah
so i thought that was really funny and
you know what i think amy looks great
and i'm such a proponent of people
getting plastic surgery like if
something's bothering you especially she
had this health condition like just do
it like i'm so not here for any
stigmatization
of plastic surgery like do it if you
want to do it don't do it if you don't
want to do it and don't judge anyone who
does it differently than you yeah and i
think also i'm such a proponent of
people doing whatever they want to do
and it's also very refreshing when
people share what they've had done
because also it's like it's it's not
like you know oh i just you know this is
all natural and then at least i'm 45 and
i look the best i've ever looked and it
leaves like other people being like well
um is there something i don't know me
why didn't that happen to me and so i
think it's nice when there's
transparency and also you can like see
the results and see if you know this is
something that might work for you i
completely completely agree so
i love this for amy i think she looks
great
and
here's to getting more plastic surgery
in 2022 oh that's exciting you have
anything planned
i mean liposuction is definitely on the
list
perhaps like a facelift
um a breast reduction and lift
i don't know my knees are a little saggy
oh in 2022 a labiaplasty
um
i'm open to anything for real
okay cool even though i'm like petrified
of going under anesthesia i've never
been under anesthesia have you
no it so freaks me out because i one
time saw an episode of neptuck okay we
know
yes yes and we know and they were at
dennis's funeral
shut the [ __ ] up okay
i won times on episode no you're not
everyone knows what you're talking about
nobody wants to hear they don't nobody
wants to be re-traumatized okay fine so
that's why i'm afraid of um
going under anesthesia but for the right
procedure liposuction i would do it yeah
i think is that outpatient
no i think you have to like be asleep
oh okay
but then you get a flat stomach so it's
like
even if [ __ ] does go wrong
with the anesthesia i have a flat
stomach might be worth it something to
think about something to think about are
you ready for our fifth and final story
only if it's the fifth and final story
that's brought to you by blue land
did you know that an estimated five
billion plastic hand soap and cleaning
bottles are thrown away each year and if
that's not bad enough each bottle can be
made of more than 90 water so it's a
lose-lose situation for the planet and
it's 20 22 stop wasting water and
throwing out more plastic get blue
land's revolutionary refill cleaning
system instead so the idea is simple
from blue land and it's beautiful you
buy the bottle once and refill it
forever there's no more plastic waste
the only thing you need to discard is
your outdated idea that eco-friendly
products are just more expensive and
less effective you fill blue lands
beautiful instagramable bottles with
warm water pop in one of the hand soap
or spray cleaner tablets and within
minutes you have powerful cleaning
products in the most beautiful scents
like iris agave
lemon lavender eucalyptus so their
best-selling clean essentials kit they
also have the hand soap duo and the
plastic free laundry and dishwasher
tablets blue land has something for
every inch of your home and backed by
very popular demand is the toilet tablet
cleaner and you should get that before
it sells out because it's really popular
product this whole concept is so genius
you keep the bottles forever you fill
with water and their tablets the
solutions work great whether it's a
bathroom cleaner toilet cleaner
laundry it all works really really well
and it's so good for the planet and it
smells so good and it's very chic like
the bottles are very nobella approved
you know yeah no i have all the products
so i the pink bathroom cleaner is in my
bathroom it looks so cute and then
there's like these purple little toilet
bulb um
pods that you just like throw into your
toilet bowl everything is so
aesthetically pleasing and i love that
you just it you don't have to like
constantly be buying new stuff like you
get a refill of the pods when your time
is here but the bottles are massive so
they last so long yeah and right now you
can get 20 off your first order when you
go to blueland.com toast that's 20 off
your first order of any blue land
product at blueland.com toast
blueland.com
toast
great okay our fifth and final story
some questions are being answered about
cheer but also they are leaving us with
more questions so the cheer producers
have some explaining to do because it
turns out
the thing that isn't explained in cheer
is that navarro and trinity valley are
competing against each other at daytona
and no one else this whole time yes okay
i knew that a quick search of the
daytona schedule reveals that they are
the only teams participating in the
advanced large coed junior college
division division in march 2020 monica
coach monica confirmed to slate that
they are each other's only rivals but
said that it's not that simple she said
we're two of the best teams out there it
doesn't matter that we're in a junior
college division nobody wants to compete
against us so we had a lot of questions
about cheer yesterday and we've gotten a
lot of answers in the last 24 hours that
we need to share first of all the thing
about them just like staying in college
forever is true and they can really stay
in college forever they leave the team
so why did it morgan that's my i think
she just was ready to move on with her
life like now she's a celebrity like she
doesn't want to be dedicating like eight
hours of her day to cheer practice like
you know at some point like you need to
move on yeah i think for other people
there's still more to be had there i
think for
like someone like gabby butler like her
career her whole life and she's been in
like a celebrity the whole time while
being a cheerleader so like being a
cheerleader for as long as possible is
what's best for her career agreed
whereas i feel like morgan is more of
like an influencer now yes and less
cheer focused and also like you can't do
i mean i guess some people are doing it
forever but it's so hard on the body
it's like so hard on the mind it's very
intense and it leaves little room for
anything else like for you to even think
about let alone do so i understand
having to eventually move on but pretty
much they can keep enrolling in like one
credit
every single year class and keep
cheering at navarro unt until they
decide that they don't want to so no
one's like getting kicked out of there
and what i find interesting about this
whole like navarro and trinity valley
being the only two schools in their
categories
um
i don't think it takes away from like
how talented they are but i do wonder
how they match up to four-year colleges
you know like
scoring-wise are they are both these
teams better
yeah it sounds like they are better but
like since it's a
league of two teams why not just throw
them in with some other teams because
otherwise it really does like kind of
take the
space it lowers the stakes when it's
like okay either we're going to come in
first or we're going to come in second
or you could argue
you could argue with stakes you could
argue if you ain't first you're last
right that would apply here
right so but at the end of the day like
you still get a trophy for second place
so yeah i think i know i mean if there
were other teams in the league like they
would still be one and two but it's just
like such a weird coincidence that
there's only two junior colleges they're
30 minutes away from each other they're
both competing at the highest level of
cheerleading and they're down the road
from one another like that's the
weirdest part there's a whole country
out there of cheer teams and these two
are just in their league junior colleges
tons of junior colleges everywhere yeah
but why don't they compete against other
junior colleges
i think that those they're literally the
only two junior colleges in the country
that have cheerleading teams
got it that qualify
yeah it's extremely confusing
yeah
very weird
so
we're getting some clarity and i'm glad
to have it
um
i'm gonna finish cheer today and like i
said i'm i'm still up to the jury of it
all
which i feel very upset about like
and i've seen a lot there's like a lot
of um
conversations being had around because
you know gabby butler and monica like
are just having a hard time digesting it
and gabby's like standing by jerry um
and it's just really hard to watch
you know there's have you watched that
part yet
i haven't finished the episode but
gabby's like that's my friend like i'm
not just leaving him she's like
struggling with it and clearly so is
monica and yeah a lot of people are
upset with um
a lot of people there there's a lot of
conversation about just like the way
that they filmed it in general like
first of all having the two victims like
speak out and tell their story which i
felt like was if you're going to give
jerry a platform which they did of
course the biggest platform then it was
necessary yeah no i thought that that
was a
especially since the boys were willing
and wanting to talk about it like that
move seemed totally fair fair to me and
and and really
had us get a better sense of the story
because when i was going into watching
cheer season two i had almost forgotten
all this stuff with jerry and then even
when i remembered i was like well what
exactly happened and they're letting you
know exactly what happened so there's a
lot of different perspectives you're
hearing from like former um
like the woman who's a lawyer have you
heard from her yet who was
she's a larry nassar victim and she's
representing
those twins right so they got like a lot
of people's perspectives on it and from
like a legal sense and just in the cheer
world and
then of course like monica and gaby and
people who like knew him but clearly
didn't know him and i think that they
did a pretty good job with it but i know
a lot of people have uh
weren't happy
well i think there's like two sides of
the coin some people are like they
didn't go hard enough on jerry he's
literally a pedophile and then other
people are like having a hard time
digesting because he was literally for
like a year and a half
america's sweetheart yeah and how do you
go from being that to literally being in
a prison cell for
sexual facing
facing 15 years minimum
it's it's very shocking to go from that
to that yeah
it is and it's like that's shocking for
us and we just like watched him one
season on cheer we don't even know him
we don't even know him and so like for
the for the
his cheerleading fellow cheerleaders
mm-hmm and i think the woman who was the
lawyer said it like you think you know
someone and you just like never do
no and ladarius was like very much
done with jerry like he cut that off
real quick but gabby was like not
not able to do that yeah
so i'll finish that and then we'll talk
about that tomorrow but we still have tv
recap what should we do next tv recap or
dear toasters i think tv recap me too
susan finale of vanderpump rules um it
was really good because it was literally
like brock and china being moronic and
there were a couple moments that i
really loved first of all when lala was
like before there was rockell and james
and before there was lala and randall
there was lala and james and i don't
even really feel like she needed to
justify
why she told james only because sheena
and brock are two of the dumbest people
ever okay they told everyone they were
getting engaged all right i wouldn't
have done it but fine then they told
everyone like and we had this plan so it
was out there you sat everyone down 15
people and told them
it's out the fact that you're mad at
james finding out when you literally
told everyone no we all see like the
last few episodes they were like no
one's ever gonna know no one's ever
gonna know and like james and raquel
they'll never know and it's like they
only know now because you told people
the
the way that that unfolded first of all
i'm so glad that lala told james one
because like yeah now it's out there and
james should know that this was
happening behind his back two for the
sake of the show like we needed this
blow-up to occur as opposed to just like
waiting for the reunion it's like eight
months later and it's it's all diluted
and nobody cares when james markell are
broken up like right
this was like a fight that needed to
happen
and i i mean personally and i know
people probably are like just wanting to
blame lala for starting drama but like
these last few episodes have shown brock
in the absolute worst light like i am
done with this man and just when you
think it can't get any worse he tells
sheena to put on her ring once they're
getting kicked out of the party like
they were standing when they were
standing outside the party and like he
was leaving they were like and she was
staying kicked out of the party and they
were it was just like this
crazy
delusional moment and it's like a no the
answer to this is to put on your ring
also when sheena was talking to lisa and
telling her that they got engaged and
like showing her the ring in her purse
like
these people are insane
no and you know what lisa has literally
become my favorite person on the show i
never thought i would say that one
because she's not pretending to be
everyone's boss anymore like she's now
like an advisor a friend a mentor
and the way she comes for sandoval for
being completely delusional about his
restaurant is a beautiful thing to see
and the way she was just telling it
straight to sheena like what the [ __ ]
was was gorgeous like i've really come
to love and respect lisa me too also
when she took james and markell for that
picnic and like they were all getting
emotional about like how far james has
come and like i don't know if i'm just
like anything would make me emotional
but i was like really feeling it i was
like this is really beautiful and i'm
i'm upset that james and raquel aren't
together anymore also that's what i was
feeling i was like this is cute but
they're not even together raquel looked
so sickeningly stunning stunning they
should have just gotten married that day
and i know like what went wrong we'll
find out next week hopefully i mean and
now of course there are so many things
and like you see her family like really
doesn't like him and especially the dad
and i understand like he's a reality tv
star and then his second job is a dj and
he has like a really bad attitude
sometimes he doesn't always treat raquel
like the best but she has blossomed so
much like from the time they started
dating until now and of course like
she's had she's grown and i'm sure like
so many things have happened in her life
but at one constant has been james and i
think the person that she is like that
we watched last night at the engagement
party like is a testament to like how
james has loved her over the years
though flawed
i agree and it was like this culmination
for her like with her speech and like
she's just like really
it was like annoying to watch because
like she's made all this progress and
like we've all made this progress we're
ready for her and james and like they're
not even getting married and i thought
the way that they did the speech like
i'm sure other people were like i
thought it was great i thought it was
great it was such a great solution she
like of not everybody i hate i hate at
weddings when people stand up there with
their phones and like are looking and
reading at their phones it's terrible so
tacky even if she did that like she's
such a nervous speaker and not everyone
who's a nervous public speaker needs to
become a professional public speaker but
sometimes you have things in your life
where you need to speak and you need to
like find a crutch in a way to get
through it i thought that the way that
they did it was so cute and hysterical
and the fact that like james was telling
her what to say and it was all very
james um
friendly approved so funny and i thought
it was cute it was like a cute dynamic
in their relationship i have no issue
with it
hysterical i loved it i thought it was
great
yeah
um so
honestly for me it was such an
uncomfortable episode like from start to
finish but one of the most uncomfortable
moments was lala versus ariana when
ariana was just like i was born cool
[ __ ] like and lala's like i honestly i
can't when you do this it's so cringy
like and ariana just kept going like it
was so painful so
painful
obviously like i'm team lala all the way
like it was so cringy i don't know why
ariana like goes into that mode of like
having to imitate lala it's it really
was painful and cringy to watch it's
horrible it's like no way to win an
argument no and i think that she thinks
that she won i'm sure twitter thinks
that she won because she was like i was
born cool
it's just not a cool thing to say no the
whole thing was really awful i honestly
wish they edited it out
i know it was like
it was not good yeah
um but all in all i thought it was a
great season finale in the sense like it
felt conclusive but there's still like
so much tension that the reunion like
should be good i thought it was a really
good way to end the season
yeah the reunion looks really good i
mean
there's so much i think there's a lot of
tension within the group that'll be good
for the reunion and then also like the
lala and randall stuff but it's just
gonna be
i don't know i'm not looking forward to
the shot in freud
i know like everyone just like being so
happy that like lala was starting all
this drama and like now she's the one
i'm not into it yeah we'll see how it
plays out hopefully they'll have some
compassion and also seems like lala
isn't you know holding back and
is like the fact that her whole thing
now is like i just wish people told me
because apparently like everyone knew
shady stuff about randall and no one
told her i think he's really congruous
with the way that she acts on the show
so
i think she's literally nothing to be
ashamed of honestly i agree
but it's just everything she said she
would do about her situation she did
there's uh
there i have respect for that
yeah she walks the walk she talks to
talk
and you know what like everyone could
learn a thing or two from her yeah so
i'm i am looking forward to the reunion
and the season turned out to be
something i guess thanks to brock and
sheena
i'm very grateful to brock and sheena
for their delusion illusional land i i
can't even explain to you how i felt
watching last night's episode like
what do you think was the worst part i
just had such a visceral like physical
reaction to i had second hand
embarrassment everything that was
happening and i'm one i'm so glad that
sheena even said like we're not getting
married like when she spoke to him on
the boat and she was like no this is a
no
it was
i wonder how she even came to that
conclusion though
probably the worst was when they were
sharing that they were engaged to
everyone and like no one
cared no one cared and she was like i
don't want to make it out at us but like
you're making it about you and like
really when you saw that engagement
party and like i probably cost them so
much it was and they stopped talking
about how much it was so it must have
been a lot it was so well thought out
and
then like so seeing all of that in the
context of like what they were trying to
do it just made them look even shittier
i completely agree because it was a
stunning weekend like a really thought
well thought out party yeah
yeah um for me i think the worst part
was like when she opened her purse and
was showing lisa the ring
yeah
oh my god it was it was so cringy i i i
can't remember love i'm sorry that's why
like i literally die for sheena like
she's literally no self-awareness she's
the perfect reality star and also the
thing about gina like delusional no
self-awareness this sad and the other
but like
has a good heart
very sweet girl and so i have no really
like aside from you know just reality tv
show stuff i have no issue like with
sheena or whatever but i i think with
brock it's coming from a different place
brock is very problematic yeah yeah and
the fact that like he's just trying to
do everything on everyone else's dime
like it's crazy and i i thought the
comments i love that they heart back to
the randall stuff and that like james
and i thought james handled himself
completely respectably and said
everything that i was thinking agreed
yeah
um
so we'll recap the reunion next week i'm
very much looking forward to it since so
much has happened and we're going to
dive into your toasters and you know
what jackie i actually texted you the
deer toasters i have like a frog in my
throat and i just think it's probably
better if you do the deer toasters my
voice is like disgusting today
okay here we go and dear toasters is
brought to you by manscaped roses are
red violets are blue we love shaved
balls how about you
valentine's day is coming and we just
know the gift to give that's someone
special
for any and all occasions this
valentine's day it's time to give him
the gift that four million men worldwide
trust from manscaped the leaders in
below the way screaming use our
exclusive offer at manscaped.com code
toast for 20 off and free shipping
so
this is the product he's going to love
and you are going to love whether it's
your boyfriend your husband
it's a gift for him and a gift for you
the performance package 4.0 from
manscaped is the gift that every guy
needs in their life to make each and
every day just a little bit more special
so the product that he's probably gonna
love most which ben loves is the
lawnmower 4.0 it's their electric
trimmer it's so good it's very sleek it
looks great on your counter it works
really really well
um and their electric trimmer is
designed to trim the hair on loose skin
and their advanced skin safe technology
reduces cuts and nicks on the delicate
areas like the testicles and it even has
an led spotlight so we can shave
anywhere any time of day whether it's
pitch black you just need to shave your
balls you know um they have amazing
products at
manscaped but again that trimmer is a
personal favorite ben loves the shed
travel bag the anti-chafing boxer briefs
um and you can make sure that your boy
smells good with the signature scent the
manscaped refined cologne
um so this is just like a one-stop shop
because i feel like boys don't have like
cosmetics they don't have like when we
go like on a trip ben like doesn't i got
everything from manscape the serums the
ball trimmer the travel case the
underwear you put it all in and you're
all set
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code toast at manscape.com that's 20 off
with free shipping at manscaped.com
code toast gift his cupid an arrow from
manscape this valentine's day also it's
a gift for him but really it's a gift
for you and those are the best kinds of
gifts
okay dear toasters first up hi claudia
and jackie love your show you are the
creme de la creme of podcast girlies oh
my god thank you so much
and by the way you guys that means cream
i know some of you listen from new
jersey we yeah at one point we're the
number one podcast in new jersey
they haven't they haven't released that
data since 2017 so i think it's okay
because there have been so many new
podcasts that have come out since then i
don't think so the 2017 analytics are
still valid because they've never right
we don't have to correct ourselves and i
think if they came out today i honestly
don't know if we would be number one in
any state just because there's so much
competition so i agree i'm okay if they
never run that poll again also if i'm
reading your toasters i will be ad
libbing a lot so that's so exciting
for some background my boyfriend and i
are both 27 and we've been together for
a little over two years
the reason i'm writing is because unless
i send my boyfriend
a direct link for a holiday birthday or
anniversary gift there's a 100 chance he
will purchase a gift from amazon don't
get me wrong i love a good amazon deal i
find a lot of really cute things on
amazon and it's super convenient i
cannot stress enough that this is not
about how much money he spends or that i
am ungrateful for things he has gotten
me in the past he has given me some fun
useful things that i do genuinely use
and like a lot but there's something
about the consistent amazon purchases
that's starting to not feel special does
that make sense i feel we are at the
stage in our relationship where we can
turn it up a notch from the practical
and useful gifts i agree
how does this toaster subtly introduce
her boyfriend to the world outside of
just jeff bezos and free prime delivery
i don't
so i don't want to be super blunt and
hurt his feelings as he is a wonderful
partner i just need some tips on how to
move this man away from useful gifts to
occasionally mix in a special thoughtful
gift without always needing to send him
a link i don't really mind sending a
link but i also do like to be surprised
this is a i want my cake and i want to
have my cake and eat it too situation so
if you think i'm being unreasonable
please tell me lol any and all advice is
welcome thank you
i just want to say the fact that you can
send a link and he will oblige is huge
like it's not like he's being cheap like
he's just
particular so the fact that you have
that you should be enormously grateful
for because some some girls don't even
have that okay yeah i completely
understand your predicament i don't
think you're being unreasonable i don't
think it's a huge deal and i think that
the fact that he is um open to getting
you whatever you want when you tell him
exactly what you want he's clearly
flexible as well but i understand
wanting to be surprised and understand
that like getting stuff from amazon
getting useful gifts it's just not
romantic and like when you're with
someone for two years like you want a
token of their love and affection so i
mean on a logistical level i would send
links to websites not to specific
products so if there's like a brand that
you like like a jewelry brand i would
assume you want more like jewelry
because that's more sentimental romantic
so i would just send the
website for the brand and be like they
have really beautiful stuff like
you choose what you makes you think of
me but i would be happy with something
from here
right so basically it's like training
wheels yeah you know first you send the
links then you take the training wheels
off you just send the website and then
at one point you'll just be riding his
bike knowing exactly what to get you
from all the websites you've ever sent
him yeah no gifts in relationships are
hard and there's something that like if
it's not
in
some people have it some people don't
but i also think some people mostly were
like trained by previous girlfriends in
order to know like what girls actually
want as gifts we talked about this a
little bit on the patreon episode that's
what i was thinking with all these
scenes on deck with um olivia she was
sharing how when her and shapiro first
got together like he used to get her
gifts like for hanukkah he got her like
you know
his apartment didn't have one right it
was just like cute that he's like
thinking of her i thought it was very
sweet it's just it's sweet that like he
wants her to have the things spend more
time at his house but at the end of the
day like you just bought yourself a
mirror right and and i just i want to
walk around with like a heart necklace
on that that makes me like think of my
boyfriend every time i see it but also
it's worth mentioning because when on
the patreon we did those love language
quizzes like how much value certain
people or emphasis they put into gift
giving and gift receiving and for some
people like it means a lot to them and
for some people it doesn't mean as much
so that's important to understand too
like maybe he's not he's not doing it
because he doesn't like you like maybe
it's just not something he understands
or values
yeah and as someone who um whose primary
language i believe was gift receiving
um that was really important to me and
it's been a journey over the years with
zach you know not every
in the beginning you know there were a
lot of misses and now we're in a rhythm
and he knows me well enough and i've
sent enough stuff that he knows that i
would like that
there's less room for error but it took
time it takes training
it does you're not alone
no and jackie's advice of you know the
training wheels think of it like riding
a bike i actually think that's really
good advice yeah or you could also like
go to the store with him
and like show him some things that you
like and then you could say like pick
what you think suits me best
right or just like lay in bed be like oh
i've really been wanting one of those
birken bags you know yeah just like drop
really obvious hints yeah and also if
you if you drop these like massive
things then obviously you're not going
to get that but then you'll get
something that shoot for the moon even
if you miss you'll land among the stars
sort of thing yeah so maybe you won't
get a birkin but you'll get a kelly
you know
exactly good luck
best of luck gift giving and boyfriends
is tough it is but it can be done
train think take the training wheels
yeah be patient
next up dear claudia and jackie i'm in
need of your beautiful stunning and
smart advice my sister's boyfriend is
about to propose to her but he's
honestly horrible he makes comments
about her weight and what she eats says
oh you're kidding me
says his you know what has a rash
because she doesn't drink enough water
and so is this literally someone writing
in about me
he says his penis has a rash because she
doesn't drink enough water
that's the most manipulative thing i've
ever [ __ ] heard in my life that's
like emotional abuse
i i'm in shock
okay i can't get past the heat comments
on her weight recently he said he wanted
to start a habit of putting his phone
into the closet every night to reduce
screen time but it was actually because
he supposedly got hacked and was
receiving nude photos of women all night
oh i hate when i get hacked and i just
get bombarded with nude photos yeah
that's like oh no someone hacked my bank
account and accidentally put a million
dollars in it
he had been hiding that for two months
my sister is 23 and she doesn't see any
of these things as red flags and has
been pushing him to propose apparently
he has the ring is there anything i can
do my family feels the same way thanks
so much a concerned sister
you need to pull out all of the stops
first of all please go talk to a doctor
and find out if his penis can get a rash
because you don't drink enough water no
he's literally not a doctor and i'm
telling you it's not possible no no i
know or if he's you know maybe sneaking
around on her and out there contracting
rashes right like gonorrhea rashes
that's so
crazy that he would put that on her
gaslighter literally gaslighter no your
whole family needs to sit down with her
like pull out all the stops this cannot
go forward
like it's time for an intervention but i
just want to say
i don't think you'll have much success
like and here's why
because if she is so blissfully happy
and and
knows that he's got
makes comments about her weight knows
that he locks his phone because he gets
nude photos like she knows all of that
and none of that bothers her and she's
still moving full steam ahead i just
don't have a lot of faith that you are
gonna have success with your
intervention i'm sorry i think there's a
chance because i think when you learn
about things like one thing at a time
you you make peace with like each thing
and you're just like
okay maybe this on its own isn't a
reason i'm going to just accept it move
forward but to be sit down by the people
that you love
all at once and also from their point of
view and knowing that these people only
want the best for you if she still
continues to go forward with him then
i'm sorry she's gonna have to learn the
hard way and that's on her but as a
sister this isn't a friend like this is
your familial duty to protect your
sister get make sure she has all of the
information at once in context
and let her make still her decision but
she needs to see it
once more
from a zoomed out lens a bird's eye view
i totally agree i'm just worried yeah
i'm not saying it's going to work but
she doesn't seem like the type of girl
who cares
i don't know she doesn't seem like she's
on this email she doesn't seem like she
doesn't care but you need to do your
part as a sister otherwise you that is
something that you're going to live with
always wondering like if i said
something before they got engaged like
once they get engaged once they get
married like it's the train has left the
station
at this point talk to your other family
members people that she loves and
respects and try and get through to her
and that's all that you need to do
it's all you can do and because she's
your sister like she will always be your
sister you don't have to worry about of
course maybe it'll put like a weird
strain on the relationship for a little
bit but it's worth it to do the right
thing agreed
third
dear claudia and jackie thank y'all and
dr for chemin for getting me through my
days you're welcome just a quick
debriefing on my [ __ ] up dating
history i've been cheated on seven times
and every story is worse than the last
gerd your loins for this debrief
i will limit myself to one my boyfriend
of two years let's call him austin and i
were on the way to meet his family and
grandparents for the first time he was a
p-john and i assumed his family would be
the same this would be so fun and easy
in the car he gets a call from his boss
that he took on speaker his boss informs
him that they need to talk because of
inappropriate relations with the
secretary i have never seen a more
guilty man in my life after he confesses
that he is indeed hooked up with his
secretary multiple times i then had to
go meet his entire family he was begging
me to go for the whole ride so i agreed
and made them fall in love with me and
had him drop me off at home and never
spoke to him again
good picture this five years later i run
into the most adorable guy at a bar and
we instantly hit it off keep in mind we
have moved away from our hometown so it
is completely out of context
we keep talking and now we've been
dating for three months unfortunately
after the first few dates we both
realized this is austin's new
stepbrother let's call him ames
and now i feel so awkward he wants me to
come to dinner with his family in a
couple weeks what the [ __ ] do i do last
time i saw austin he was dropping me off
post family dinner and now i'm supposed
to go back to said family dinner please
help and yes actual pizza and i really
like him but is this too close to home
sincerely what the [ __ ] is my life is
this a simulation wait no this is that's
crazy because honestly when you said
like that you still had to go to family
dinner
you could have burned the place to the
ground and like
like that's what i would have done right
and been so angry and like told him what
they told them what he did and just like
shot
up the joint but instead he made them
fall in love with you now you're going
to come back with aims it's the best way
to get back at austin
this is good stuff
wait austin ames isn't that a person
and not one that i yes oh my god from
yes from a cinderella story chad michael
murray's austin ames oh my god i wonder
if that's why that's that's probably why
she chose she's probably been watching
that movie
a cinderella story yeah yeah yeah that's
so funny i think this is all good and
this is the best revenge ever you may
have already met the family they love
that out of the way
you're good you're golden you're golden
and you did nothing wrong
and
the only thing is like you don't want to
make it seem like you sought out the
stepbrother to get back because you were
bitter you know like you you and you did
it so you like you have nothing to worry
about but a narcissist like who cheats
on you could see it that way yeah but so
say he wants to see it that way and like
stew in his own narcissism like you and
ames are
so happy the truth i want to know how
she figured it out
i mean it's how could she not like she
probably just saw like one instagram
post of him and his like
family or even you know when you're on
instagram like you see who follows the
person that you're following like now in
this day and age like i'm surprised it
took her this long
that's crazy but because she like just
met him rogue at a bar didn't she didn't
have a sign that said i'm austin's
stepbrother so i understand that i
understand how it's possible that you
didn't know at first but of course
yeah the more you know i love this too
embrace it and plus now you don't have
to go win over like a whole new family
like you know that they like you and you
made a good first impression and
it's just like a funny story and also it
leaves austin looking really terrible i
love to see it
completely agree cause like he's gonna
have to explain to his family like what
happened yeah exactly so that's what
you'd like to see people being held
accountable for their actions you really
do i think this is all good i'm really
happy for you i hope you and ames like
live a very happy life together together
forever children grandchildren etc
um if you want to write into your
toasters because you're having some
issues with you know relationships
friendships
dear toasters at gmail.com is the email
and we will always keep it anonymous
and if you've written to us recently and
we've given you some stellar advice we
would love to hear an update like what
happened did you take our advice did you
not take our advice did you go to the
funeral or did you go to the wedding you
know i'm still waiting to hear back from
that one so
if you
wrote to us like let us know don't leave
us hanging yeah we would like to know
but we understand that you're off living
life you know
right if you love something set it free
and if it doesn't come back right into
your toasters at gmail.com
um that's our show that's dear toasters
and our instagram is still not back up
you guys just letting you know it's
being worked on but it's not done yet
and that's our show
so we shall see you tomorrow thank you
so much for listening you can follow me
at jackie ashrae if you're looking for
something to fill the void of our
instagram
thank you so much for listening to the
morning to us the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found so spotify itunes stitcher public
radio i have radio cast box all the
places so every listen to podcasts find
nessa morning chosen leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing hump day
and we'll see you tomorrow